hello everybody today we're working on a
2023 Chrysler Pacifica
we have all keys lost so we're going to
program two keys into the system
and uh for this vehicle the connection
is back here believe it or not not on
the OBD under the dashboard
so we're gonna program prox keys
let the machine do its thing
all right follow the next screen
carefully we gotta hold the remote but
the remote next to the push the start
button
and press the unlock button
a few times there we go
that registered
okay and we're gonna do another one
hold it right here and press the unlock
button
there we go
and that is it
programmed uh 2023 Chrysler 300 I mean
Pacifica new fobs thanks for watching
guys